okay
and we ready to go we ready
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
i know nobody's here yet but welcome
back to
[Music]
your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back
wigs is
we're back it live live in full effect
because
[Applause]
i got to do it live i've been busy it is
what it is so you know
welcome back to river with griffin uh
this is alive so if you're not watching
live or you're not listening live it's
okay we're gonna get into some stuff i
went to madison wisconsin
i'm going into the arlington draft house
coming up this weekend so make sure you
check me out there and you know we're
just gonna get into some stuff like we
do every single week but once again
everybody
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay so let me put the single mic down
so that's not in the way
uh but first before we uh even start uh
let me get into wait where are we here
you know i'm looking i'm always behind
on everything um
oh man what see this i had it ready to
go and then it always messes up all
right so uh i wanna talk about helix
sleep guys
uh starting right off helix sleep big
shout out today to them take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life find your
perfect mattress at
helixleep.com griffin
okay
that that's done um welcome back to
riffing with griffin everybody um you
know i know we are live right now and i
know i don't no one knows about it cause
i just go in and do it you know this is
like uh i should have i i wasn't gonna
do it live you know what i mean but then
i thought you know what it's better it's
better just to do it live you can see
the chat right yeah uh oh can i see the
chat i don't even wait actually i'm
gonna go to this so i can see the chat
uh yeah oh that's right i should've had
i don't have the thing turned around but
i will i will go to it on my phone so i
can see the chat yeah you know what i
mean so there it is right there i got to
turn this down you know but what i got
to watch
[Laughter]
my own freaking page oh there you go so
people are here we got 40 people in the
house so so everybody just listen in
later uh you know thanks for listening
if you ever want to catch it live
if i do it live i'll do it on mondays
the day of the podcast but i should
probably put a schedule but it is what
it is so i'll occasionally look at the
chat so people are like somebody's like
notice me it's just idiot ed
it's always in my uh gaming chat and
that by the way too i also stream live
uh twitch wigs there's like a thing
there for like the twitch you see it on
the second row whatever it is like that
you can like that's that'll put that
twitch thing on the screen yeah you see
it alright so to catch me live on twitch
eric griffin gaming
you make sure you have to turn it off
too but anyways
welcome back to riffing with griffin
wiggs is here wig so tell me where you
been man what's going on with you how
come you haven't been around what's
going on you don't love you don't love
real from with griffin anymore what's
happening no well you were yeah i mean
you're always you know you're always
somewhere too um
like how you put it on me well right
before
i left i went i went on my trip i mean
you were gone a couple of times in
australia
it was a it was a hectic situation but
yeah then um i went to wyoming and then
i went to new york wyoming what were you
doing in wyoming uh well one of my
really good friends uh my next-door
neighbor that i grew up next to uh his
mom moved to wyoming and she has a
really nice house there so sweet um i
was gonna go to new york because i
booked like a video shoot out there and
then he was like oh my mom really wants
to see us like she'll get our tickets to
new york if you come to wyoming with me
first for a couple days and i was like
i mean why not it's in jackson hole
wyoming so
jack there's a yeah like the nice the
the you know like the nice where kanye
got a gutter ranch oh there's a there's
a nice part of wyoming i mean yeah it's
like it's been it's become it's it's got
like the biggest um
wealth inequality gap in the country
like it's like the biggest it's like
insane i mean it's just so there's like
the poorest of poor and then the riches
nobody that works in jackson lives in
jackson they all live in idaho like 20
miles outside that's actually a nice
part of the country when i first started
doing oh it's comedy it's beautiful when
i first started doing comedy i would go
to montana then i would drive so you
would drive to like through montana you
would drive to idaho for a show drive
back to montana and then there's
actually beautiful parts of
i've actually been to wyoming too so
yeah there's a lot of beautiful parts of
wyoming montana idaho these but these
are just places in your head you go i'm
never gonna go there but i always say
there's some really nice parts of the
united states that you know everybody
should
don't think that it's like all terrible
or whatever or rural or you know it's
like whatever you might think of it
you'd be surprised you'd be surprised
how beautiful it is uh it threw off the
united states and knows yeah in those
areas and she's like his mom is such a
such outdoorsy lady like hikes like
she's like climbed like five of the like
seven tallest mountains she's just like
insane like outdoorsy ladies skis and
snowboards and just that's her whole
life sound like you're interested
no she's cool but she's like my second
mom i've known her since i was like four
years old so so you're really interested
that's weird but um
uh shout out to amy though uh she's lit
and you like older chicks though i know
you've been like i like older chicks
but yeah not my like you know second i'm
already taking a second
yeah of course he was just like please
do it i'll put the image in my head
yeah that's a weird one but um
yeah so then she got us tickets to new
york because that's where i need to go
anyway and then
uh yeah my friend whose mom that is is
he stays in brooklyn i've known him
since i mean yeah we grew up together
and um
yeah stayed in the city a little bit my
family on my mom's side has a small
little cabin in upstate new york
literally in a
tiny town like the town's probably two
miles long and it's called it's
literally called booneville
so it's literally the boonies and then
it's not and then you gotta go down like
like giant road
moonville yeah you got to go down giant
road then you got to go down a giant
dirt road then and into like the forest
dirt road and there's only like three
other houses on the whole street shout
out to barely yeah shout out to
boomville shout out to boonville but um
that was beautiful i mean that was
amazing i wish we had some pictures to
show us i do but oh
well you get there
i know well while you figure that out
let me let me uh go into some stuff that
i wanted to get into so that's right but
it's good to see you again wigs haven't
seen you in a while good to see you yeah
yeah i'm glad to be there good to be
back um okay so let's see guys i went to
wisconsin and i was in madison wisconsin
uh comedy on state this past weekend
shout out to them they did a remodeling
of the club the green room uh the bar
area and it is fantastic i mean just
super shout out to them thanks for
having me and everybody was fun it was a
little
weird because college towns are full of
like the dumbest people on earth which
is college kids you know and i don't
mean that in like a way of like they're
they're like dumb like smart dumb
they're they're they're smart dumb you
know because they're so sensitive they
haven't lived any life experience they
don't understand nuance they take
everything literal there's everything's
black and white so when you're trying to
do comedy at a place like that sometimes
people like they don't they don't
understand like hey we're just telling
we're telling some jokes live this isn't
you know it's just you don't have to
take offense to every single thing
and if you don't like something it's
fine like i don't actually don't care
like you don't like it the best way to
do that is just to like don't laugh and
then you wait for the thing you do like
and then you laugh and then you go home
you either go i enjoyed that or you go
that wasn't my cup of tea and then we
can move on with our lives it doesn't
have to turn into this thing where we
like have to like try to cancel everyone
or whatever it is like that like you
know speaking of but anyway let me just
get back to madison then i'll go into
that next little diatribe i'm gonna go
into am i keeping my phone in my hand
trying my best to like answer like when
i'm when i'm looking at the chat for you
people that are watching live and thank
you all youtube people watching live you
guys are great
um
yeah so the club was great and so there
was sometimes was a little sensitive but
i actually like the challenge of it you
know if i'm at a place where i feel like
it's super conservative or super like
people are very sensitive to what you
say and i have to do five shows and the
first show if i'm really going at it and
people aren't responding the way i want
them to i like that because then it goes
oh you know what i have to do that means
i have to like make a small adjustment
or figure a way to so my message isn't
lost in the delivery because that's what
happens a lot your message gets lost in
the delivery or people hear some
buzzwords and they don't want to hear
anything else but their own thought you
know they they have an idea about you
they hear a word and they think in their
minds if you say this word it means
you're racist if you say that word it
means that you're homophobic or whatever
it is if you just mention something not
even like a bad word i'm saying you
could just say in a joke if you use the
word gay in a joke and you're talking
about something people don't even listen
to your point they're not all they hear
is gay and now you're homophobic if you
say woman if you're talking about women
in your thing if you just say women or
you know i have this thing with women
and then it's like well that means you
hate women that's just sometimes how
people approach comedy when they're
listening to it because they're looking
to be offended you know it's just it's
it's the world we live in right now and
then on top of with uh this thing that's
going on this controversy with dave
chappelle's last special you know we're
actually this is actually a this it's
really a a unprecedented moment right
now for and not for free speech because
this ain't about free speech because you
know free speech is not what people
think it is most people don't even
really understand the first amendment
they just like to say that but like you
can't you've heard this before but you
can't say you can't call out fire in a
movie theater if it causes a panic for
people and someone gets hurt it's on you
so free speech don't mean you could say
whatever you want and by the way even if
it was that that means you could say
whatever you want and then somebody else
can say whatever they want about what
you said and it's a circle that goes
back and forth you know so that's not
this isn't about free speech this really
is about
cancer culture about this
and cancer culture is turning into a
terrorist organization that's like you
know hey we don't like you so we want
you removed and then they say all this
stuff
we can't allow that to go we can't even
if you don't like it even if the things
they're saying about the chapel special
are true i don't think they're true
i don't think that i think that he was
poking the bear i think he was
trying to make some points i think he
was trying to make points more than he
was trying to make us laugh but that's
just neither here nor there but no
matter what he was saying i think that a
lot of his message is lost on the
delivery i really do and i think it's
just also compounded with this is now
the third or fourth special in a row
where he's
talking about this subject and you know
what unprecedented thing that someone
can like do that most people most of us
if we do a special
and everyone hates the special or not
everyone let's say you do a special and
you have something in this special and
people attack you for that you don't
normally get the chance to do another
special like a year later and address it
in your special like oh and make 20
million dollars like only chappelle gets
to do that so that's like a pretty
amazing thing so that's what he's been
doing like three in a row you know i i
think he should have moved on but that's
just my opinion but i also understand
the feeling of being like no no i'm not
going to let you all get away with what
you were saying about me so let me
double down again and talk about this
not all of us are in that position he is
in a very unique position to do that and
what i'm saying is we can't be taken
hostage you know you know you don't
negotiate with terrorists you know what
i mean you can't let
you can't let this cancer culture come
out and be like well we don't like it so
it's got to go like good for netflix
being like nah we're keeping this on
even if like even if these people
believe that he's saying these th that
it's coming across the way they're
saying if they believe he's transphobic
if they believe these things about him
if they're taking it that way and their
feelings are valid like the people that
don't like the chappelle spells for for
that reason their feelings are valid i
even saw hannah gaspy
and i'm not a huge fan of hers i don't i
don't like i'm not a that's not my cup
of tea but it doesn't matter right but i
respect what she said about being like
don't drag me in
because that's he used
sarandos the head of netflix used her in
a memo as part of her memo being like
hey we're very inclusive you know we had
this this this and we had hannah gatsby
so she was like yo don't bring bo bring
me in this and so
she has a valid point to feel that way
so it was very polarizing it was very
like it's pulling everybody but what i'm
saying though is that we cannot allow
a group of people a very small group of
people
being like dictating what can and cannot
be on our netflix our tv our airwaves
just because
they don't like it
and again you have the perfect right to
feel how you feel if you have a you have
a valid feeling because i understand
actually why someone would think what
they think because he was definitely
going at them you know he was definitely
going at them you know and it's just
like it is what it is but we have to
allow it to happen we have to allow the
discourse we have to allow like we you
have to allow things that you don't like
to be on the internet to be on
tv
and we can't just allow people to be
like yeah we don't like this take it off
you know so that's just what i have to
say about that and so to bring it back
to me
what it has done though it is made doing
stand-up in this right now a little more
challenging it's made it a little more
challenging because now people are very
much like on edge about anything that
you talk about you know they're just
going oh here we go here's another one
whatever and you know i don't i love
that i think it's great i think it's
great for comedy i think it's great for
comedians i think it's great for us to
challenge ourselves to be more
thoughtful to like like especially like
what's the point you're trying to make
you know because again going back to the
chappelle special i think that they
people are missing the points he was
making through the delivery of his jokes
and and and the feeling he had behind it
like you could tell he was a little bit
like
going at people because of how he felt
he was being people were going at him
but i felt he made some valid points
about
you know like
his thing about the baby that that
rapper he was saying like you know like
why weren't you trying to cancel him
when he murdered somebody
you know you know he murdered somebody
and there was no big internet uproar
about him still rapping but the moment
he talked about
he said something about someone uh gay
he made his whatever disparaging comment
he made now we have to get rid of him so
he was just trying to make that point
about you know the the disparaging this
this the despair what word am i trying
to say the discrepancy between like with
different movements you know he made a
great point about saying like hey i'm
jealous of the gay movement because look
at the progress they've been able to
make
and the african-american community has
not made the same kind of progress even
if we think we have not like this it
doesn't have the impact right so i mean
he was trying to make some points now if
you want to say you didn't think it was
funny if you want to say hey i don't
think this is art or i don't think that
you know he was using this platform to
like to vent if you want to say that
valid points you're having but it
shouldn't be removed is the point i'm
making so i'm out in madison and i was
trying my best and i think i did okay
i did more than okay i mean there were
people that really loved me but after
one show though this woman comes up to
me she was a little drunk
and she was foreign too and the only
reason why i say the foreign part is i
think a lot of times because she was
from the middle east and i've been to
the middle east i can tell she was
middle eastern i don't know if she was
from pakistan or she was from but she
had a thick accent and she was very
upset at me about my jokes you know and
she was coming at me you know and i
the only reason why i say about the
foreign thing is because i think
sometimes context is lost in a language
translation in people's head i think
sometimes uh nuance and uh
uh
sarcasm and uh certain things that make
jokes funny
you know uh
some people for them they just take
things literal you know because she was
like you know you you you you were
talking about women and you you didn't
talk about men and it just wasn't true
you know it's just the the jokes i say
about women are just they're just
funnier than what you know i mean it's
the ones that punch hard right but i was
i thought anyways
if you're in a show guys just just let
me just give you a tip
if you're at a show and you're sitting
in the crowd and there's like 300 people
in this show 200 people whatever it is
right
and everyone is laughing or a majority
of the people are laughing you look
around and you see white people black
people
old young different types of ethnicities
different ethnic backgrounds different
you know different social economics you
could tell some people are rich some
people are not what all the differences
in the crowd and they're all laughing at
the jokes that you're listening to but
you don't like it
i think you need to take that into
account before you walk up to a comic
acting like what he's doing is wrong
i mean the arrogance of someone to think
that because they didn't like something
in a crowd of the people that everyone
seems to be enjoying themselves
you know it's like [ __ ] off
you know like just take that just go
home like ah i didn't like the guy that
was my cup of tea and everyone in that
room was also wrong like that's you go
do that on your own now that being said
if you're the one female in a room and
let's say it's 90 guys and all the guys
are laughing at some like you know
uh sort of misogynistic or whatever you
might interpret it to be joke you might
have a bigger you might have a better
point you might have a better point to
be like but then even at the same time
what are you doing there you know what i
mean like if this is some rah-rah frat
party and where you know we're speaking
in your comic is speaking to the crowd i
don't think it's on you to be like you
know hey this is wrong or or like i
didn't like this
because then everybody there's kind of
like okay well maybe you should leave
you know what i mean and and even if
it's something bad man you know like i
don't think it's like if you're jewish i
don't think you want to go to the nazi
meet and greet you know what i mean you
know you're going to be there being like
hey guys i don't think this is good
they're going to be like well what are
you doing here we're talking you know
what i mean like and i'm not saying
that's right but know your audience man
like know where you are taking take that
into account and so i just think that
these people that go to comedy shows and
they just think oh i just heard the
worst thing ever like look around
people are enjoying themselves maybe
it's you you ever think that you ever
think it could be just you but i don't
know
let me go to the chat and see what these
people are saying
yes this is actually live hello everyone
i am live riffing with griffin thank you
for being here people to listen in later
uh on all the podcast platforms i also
thank you guys
for
being here
um and i appreciate you so one other
thing that happened at uh
wisconsin and wigs you can come back on
the screen i want to ask you something
about because you went to wyoming like
what was what did you feel um what was
the covid uh situation like there did
you feel like was everybody masked up or
was it just the kind of thing where you
felt willy-nilly or what was the feeling
out there in wyoming i'm trying to
remember i don't
did you have a map were you wearing a
mask
um i think i i mean
there's nothing to say i mean i don't
know there's like a blast we are live no
well i'm i mean i'm vac so
technically i have the choice right um
but
i'm trying to remember i think it was
just you know half and half uh i mean
it seemed like one of those places where
you know most of the people didn't
support wearing a mask um
is the vibe i got but i'm trying to
remember i think it was just kind of
half and half like you didn't have to
inside but it's also like you know a
very small
town area and everyone's pretty spread
out so i mean
obviously if i'm if i was around people
and going to stores i always wear my
mask oh you're that guy all right i can
appreciate that i mean just i mean i'm
back so i guess it doesn't matter either
way but just yeah
you know here's the thing though is like
to make other people feel we'll see now
now that's a point that's a great way to
say that yeah i think that's the only
real reason i mean you know but it's
like but they well one thing the
misinformation is they shouldn't have
put the they should not have put
information out saying that if you got
the vaccine you'll never get coveted oh
that was never true sure what i'm just
saying that that was never true right
they should never have they should never
have let that myth
sort of grow it kind of caught fire so
then all of us got vaxxed and then when
then were like hey you still got to wear
a mask we were all like what what are we
going to wear
and when we went
to no masks completely and then they
pulled back like almost immediately you
know and they're like oh wait wait wait
wait we got to do masks again you know
yeah yeah yeah
so somebody's just telling me right now
janine thank you in for the super chat
and the thing but she was telling me
right now i really want to see you in
arlington this weekend but i already
have tickets to schultz well i didn't
even know schultz was in
so that's going to be a challenge so me
and andrew schultz are gonna be in uh
the arlington area at the same time but
you know it is what it is but come check
me out in arlington for all you guys
that are listening right now all right
so okay that's a good uh thing to go
into what i wanted to go into uh wigs
about uh but anyways guys so i'm in
i'm in madison okay so i'm doing a meet
and greet and you know not all comics do
meet greets anymore i mean i feel like
i've been you know i'm getting myself
healthier i've lost weight you know i
took a i took an iv before i went i get
like an immune boost iv sometimes before
i go to a place where i'm like hey i
don't know what's going on i just gotten
it oh it's because i went to cabo i got
an immune boost iv so i feel like i
still had that going on i'm taking my
vitamins i'm trying to be pretty healthy
um and so and i'm also vaccinated you
know so i'll do a meet and greet you
know i'm i'm i'm telling myself i'm
taking that risk you know so i'll do a
meet and greet but so a guy comes up and
then like you know we're taking a
picture it's like a few of him and his
couple of his friends
and you know they got their masks off so
a lot of people ask me okay everything
my mask off and i'm like you know it's
fine you know we're just taking a quick
pick i don't breathe
you know what i mean and then then they
can go
but the guy goes he has his mask on and
then he goes oh oh let me take this off
what am i a liberal you know and when he
said that i thought to myself
man that's messed up
you know it's messed up
that this has been so
politicized
that and that's how people feel about it
so it ain't about health and safety it's
not about like what whig said about
hey i'm trying to make the people around
me comfortable so that's also why i do
it so i mean that's a that's a thing you
know so the fact that this guy said that
about he made it like where people do
think of it like that that this is a
democrat
republican conservative progressive
issue
instead of it being about a health and
safety issue and the thing too about it
is this crazy about like about even with
health and safety sometimes i feel like
a lot of these places it ain't even
about health and safety first it's about
liability first
it's about optics first so like a more
liberal place might be like well we have
to show everybody that we care about
this as opposed to the main point being
about health and safety uh i'll give you
another example like another analogy for
this is like you know it's like when you
go to the airport we still got to take
our shoes off we go to the airport we
take our shoes off some of us have to if
you don't got tsa pre you gotta take
your shoes off it's annoying it's so
stupid to me right but we do it but why
do we do it we do it because
two guys
had a shoe bomb that didn't even go off
like it didn't even work
and we still taking our shoes off eight
nine ten years later
still taking our shoes off
because some people
try didn't even
failed
a failed attempt at blowing up a plane
with a shoe bomb now we taking our shoes
off unless you're tsa pre right oh this
is gsa free but the point is it just
means what you pay more and then get
like a no no they do they do they do
like a small little background check and
then you have to like have like uh you
know which is fair too it's like you
know i don't think everybody should be
lumped into like so just because a
couple of guys from a terrorist
organization or that are in cahoots with
a terrorist organization just did they
want to blow up a plane so now it means
that we all are trying to blow up a
plane or have the possibility to so
they're they you think they have a
little common sense so they have like
these things in place but my point is my
point is this
we still do it and why do we do it even
if we think it's dumb even if we don't
like it we go well i understand why
we're doing this it's because lives can
be lost the very very small small small
slim chance that someone actually makes
a good shoe bomb this is why we're doing
this right so i think it's the same
thing with the masks but unlike the shoe
bomb
kovit has actually killed
a million people so
just statistically i think wearing a
mask
is
you know
and i hate it listen i hate wearing
masks guys i hate wearing masks i don't
go out because of it i don't i i go to
shows i come home i i don't even i don't
like going anytime i gotta wear a mask
i'm like oh i gotta do this i hate it i
hate it i hate traveling it just bugs me
all day it's so annoying but i do it i
do it i do it because
you know it's like whatever but i just
hate the political climate i hate that
we've politicized it i hate that it's a
democrat republican issue when it should
just be an issue about all of us
galvanizing our feelings to
to beat this thing you know and it's
just like you know and then and then
they get on like i saw like the i said
you know i had the news thing on my
phone so this stuff came up and they
were like talking about joe rogan the
view that you know you know the joe
rogan had sanjay gupta on this podcast
and they had a really great back and
forth discourse about getting vaccinated
and not getting vaccinated you know and
joe rogan has the opinion of like i
think if you're a healthy person there's
other ways to beat this you don't have
to just be vaccinated you know and so so
there's people that get on him they
think that's a dangerous message but you
know what it's nuanced you know
my point about it is like hey if you're
these people that are anti-vaxxed that
are filling up the hospitals because
that's the majority of people that are
in the hospital because of covet or
people that are not vaccinated that's
just a fact okay but here's the thing
don't use joe rogan
if you obese if you're at home fat out
of shape unhealthy you got pre-existing
conditions don't be like well i'm not
gonna joe rogan is rich in shape he's a
black belt in jiu jitsu this is a guy
that's got money and
and and and and wherewithal he got you
know he he's got the best vitamins the
best the best everything the best
treatments you're not on that level so
don't use him as a reason for you to be
like well i'm also not going to nah
you you i don't want to hear you like i
don't want to hear somebody fat out of
shape talking about i'm not going to
take the vaccine because those are the
people that are getting hit the most
to look at the statistics
obesity is running through people the
covet is running through the obese
community i'm talking about running
through it man so not everybody's on the
same level so not everybody should be
you know speaking on it in the same way
but you know they it becomes politics
everything's politics and it's just like
damn can we just have a conversation so
i love that that guy went on joe rogan's
podcast and they had a really great back
and forth they got contentious at times
but that's what happens when you're
having a discussion about something so
serious you know and so it's like if we
can't do that if we can't have that kind
of back and forth if people are just
going to sit in their own echo chamber
and yell at the other side like you're
wrong you're stupid you're whatever what
are we how are we going to how are we
going to move forward man how the hell
are we going to move forward
all right let's go we got to
do let me do the uh the things wigs let
me just find this
all right guys
so
helix sleep you know he licks sleep guys
um i got a i got a helix sleep mattress
and i mean it changed my sleeping life
sleeping is so important when every time
i go to my the health place they're
always talking about
um how does how's your sleep i have this
consultation they'll do though they'll
weigh me to do my bmi they'll do all
this stuff but the thing they always ask
me about is how are you sleeping are you
sleeping and i think sleep is important
and i've been having back issues so
sleeping on this mattress that i got
it's really changed it and so i feel a
lot better the big thing about healing
sleep they got this sleep quiz it just
takes two minutes to complete and they
match you to your body type and sleep
preference to fit you with the perfect
mattress for you like i'm a side sleeper
so my mattress is you know it's a little
softer some people are firm they even go
by your body type like if you're a
bigger person they're going to have a
more firm mattress that could take all
that weight or or you know if you're a
light i mean they have they have a bunch
of mattresses to choose from and you
just take this quiz so it's perfect so i
want you to take a look at that uh on
helix sleep so you look so if you're
looking for a mattress like i say take
the quiz you order the mattress if you
don't like it you they'll
they'll they'll come get it from you you
know what i mean you don't got to go to
the mattress store anymore
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 and by gq
and wired magazine so go to
helixsleep.com
griffin take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
griffin
all right
so there's that one and guys we are not
done i also want to talk about better
help get that one on the screen wigs
better help better help guys
i am a big advocate of therapy therapy
is great i have take therapy i actually
take a couple of therapies i have my own
personal therapy and then i have like
some family therapy with you know i just
i just think that it is such a powerful
tool for yourself
i know therapy gets a bad stigma and
it's it shouldn't i want you to
understand something that therapy don't
solve your problems what it does is it
helps you pinpoint
the root causes of things it helps you
recognize the patterns that might be
making you feel the way you feel with a
professional who can translate that
because this is what they do
you know and we're still dealing with a
lot right now we're still in the
pandemic we're still trying to deal with
like our jobs and our lives and what's
going on and how we're gonna move
forward so you're gonna get you're gonna
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions all without having to go to an
uncomfortable doctor's office it's more
affordable than traditional online
traditional therapy online counseling
and and financial aid is even available
there's a lot of things we're dealing
with guys stress anxiety we're dealing
with things with our relationship we're
still dealing with this pandemic this is
convenient most importantly it's
affordable
and you know you could check out
testimonials on their website so go to
better help
um i want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
griffin for 10 off your first month
start living a happier
better life go to better help thanks
guys
all right
so we got that we got we got that in we
got that yeah
all right let me look at the chat real
quick uh hello everybody in the chat
thanks for being here
um
anyways thanks for being here
people are looking at you know yeah wigs
is a cat guy which i'm really surprised
at i'm an animal guy in general yeah but
on your if you go to wig's instagram
there's always some little pussycat i
got
what's going on with you are you a cat
guy are you catch over dogs
no i don't think i could choose that's
what i'm saying and this whole
experience so
we took there's a ton of stray cats in
our alley i have two cats um
one of these strays got pregnant um and
i mean she's just gonna keep having
these cats i guess i should get her
spade just would be the yeah super
responsible thing to do so you get the
neighborhood [ __ ] living
yeah i mean we feed her and she had
these kittens and the kittens would come
eat the food and they're really cute so
i couldn't resist grabbing them and i
was going to keep one of them and give
the other one away but now it's looking
like unfortunately we're going to have
to keep both of them oh my god they're
brother and sister and it would be very
very hard to tear them apart from each
other you mean from you
yeah but even from each other i mean you
know they were
these feral little kittens and now
they're
finally used to inside life and um
getting along but the whole experience
made me one realize i'm never doing this
again and that
two
um
that's it for you well it was so much no
more like no more empathy for me like
one the emotional
stress stress the two the general stress
three
like tearing it apart from i mean
grabbing the kittens i had to trap the
kittens and bring them inside and doing
that in front of the mom was
hard and then four it's like i gotta i
had to drop like 500 bucks to get them
all like their shots and everything yeah
so it's just uh
do you have health insurance
yeah i don't have cat health insurance
i'm just saying it's like it's amazing
how expensive it is
i mean it was ridiculous but i mean i
knew that going into it so
the expense is the least of it but i was
just it's just too much
stress in general so i'm not going to do
that again but
um it made me realize i just i really do
uh love animals and all right well there
it is guys there it is wiggy loves
animals all right we're winding down
guys so i want to do the the last thing
i want to talk about two things i want
to talk about these two shows on
um the apple tv that i'm watching i
don't know how many apple tv watchers
are out there and i you know at first i
didn't think apple tv was going to
survive but they actually got some good
shows they got ted lasso and they got
some really good shows but there's a
couple of shows that i'm watching and i
want to talk about right now the first
one is this new show it's called the
foundation and i'm looking it up on my
phone right now just so i can have like
uh some information and i'm sure wigs is
doing the same thing for for you guys
that are watching but the foundation man
is a really great show dude
it is
i mean i don't even know how to explain
it i'm not gonna spoil it for you but
you know it's just it's sort of like
this futuristic you know other galaxy
show where there's this like you know
overlord empire that like is running the
whole you know the galaxy because
they're the biggest force in the galaxy
and and there's this guy his name is
harry selden and he has this like math
equation he's a math per he's a math
whiz and through math he has seen
uh the future and he thinks that it the
future of this empire the whole place
it's going to crumble it's not going to
last
and he's predicting his future and then
you know he called and then and so
there's like different worlds that have
different like religions and different
backgrounds alien life and they're all
under the thumb of this
empire and but the show is just really
well acted
um it's a lot of information to absorb
so you really got to pay attention to
find out where they are because they
jump forward in the future they'll jump
back to explain things and and it's like
i'm on like episode 5 i believe it is
and i just i really i really enjoy it so
like if you're into like star wars if
you're into that kind of stuff and you
know because it's very star wars-y
actually when it comes to like you know
the the galactic empire there's always
an evil empire right it looks super star
wars yeah it's a very it's got a star
wars-y feel to it but i just really
enjoy it i enjoy the storytelling i
enjoy the the intrigue the drama uh they
and i enjoy some of the some of the
little things that they did to explain
why the empire is still in power um
and it's just uh you know i i don't i
don't really recognize i i recognize a
couple of the actors in the show but
it's like jared harris lee pace uh i
used to watch how to get away with
murder on abc and this one kid is is on
the show
uh
let me see if i can see where he is what
is oh his name is alfred enoch oh he was
in harry potter he was like the black
kid in harry potter uh so yeah he's
great
anyways it's well acted it's well
performed i'm not gonna spoil it for you
and i would like to see anybody that's
watching it if you've watched it i mean
what do you think anybody in chat watch
this
um and if you're and if you haven't
watched it you start watching it make
sure you know you can put a little
message on my instagram being like hey i
saw that man and i hated it or i liked
it or whatever i mean i'm into that i'm
into this kind of stuff it was very like
i said it's very dramatic and it's i
love the the space stuff too the the the
special effects are great you know it
looks like apple spent a bunch of money
on this show and i like when they do
that i like when production companies
networks or whoever put some money into
into these things yeah they definitely
had a budget
yeah it looks like it was a huge budget
but i i didn't think apple tv was
working i thought they were really uh
you know going under but you know it
seems to be because they got a bunch of
new shows that are coming out i saw a
will ferrell show that's coming out they
got another like sort of it's called
invasion and then the sam o'neil the
dude from jurassic park stars and nat
and it's about aliens coming so that's
the show i'm gonna check that one out
too i love fantasies fine science
fiction and that kind of stuff but the
foundation is a pretty i think it's a
pretty good show i get i give it a i
give it a a moderate thumbs up it's not
like the greatest show i've ever seen
but i really enjoy it and i look forward
to it coming out every week i'm glad you
can't binge it i'm not a fan of binging
even though i love binging i am a fan of
binging but i understand why you
shouldn't let people binge i love the
build up i love being oh man i want to
see it and then i get to know the
characters i get to think about it some
more so i enjoy that process so check
out the foundation that's one of the
shows that i really enjoy on uh apple tv
the other show i enjoy in apple tv is um
says two episodes of that is the budget
of one movie oh wow it doesn't say what
that is yeah oh okay wow well it depends
on what kind of movie too though it
could be like uh
it could be like a shitty you know in
indie films right it doesn't it doesn't
give me a price
yeah yeah so um okay the other show this
is another show i really really like
this one it's called c
uh this one is dope and i talked about
it before because season one was a
little like
you know what i mean it was it it i i
loved the concept of it though it's a
drama series and it stars um what's his
name aquaman
um uh what's this what the hell's his
name jason momoa yeah i always call him
jason mimosa for some reason but his
name is jason momoa
um and this
this show okay so i could tell you about
the show so it's called c uh like s-e-e
um it's about like it's like 500 years
in the future from now
and
something happened to all of humanity
and everyone lost their sight so
everyone's blind and this is now 500
years in the future when now
they know how to live without sight okay
and but sight is coming back to the
world
and you know it's like these sort of
tribal
tribal
kingdoms who are you know trying to you
know just no matter what c or not men
are men you know human nature's human
nature so they have kings and queens and
leaders and councils and and it's very
shakespearean like it really is it's
such a great show man like this i i find
myself in season two just so like
wrapped up in the story and the
characters and it is well acted like
jason mamoa is acting his ass off this
looks really sick like you i believe
everything that's happening like like
because you have to remember that
everyone's blind right and so they've
come up with this sort of language uh
that that that they have you know it's
like bird box mixed with the revenant
yeah something like that can i finish
talking about this damn show
i forgot when wig's here he don't he
don't he think it's his show
so to see so like they have this like
how they communicate and like how they
walk and and and i can tell that the
producers took a lot of thought into and
the writers and the creators were like
all right here's how these people
function without sight and it's great
you know they they they snap at each
other they they they hit things and
they're like and the fighting is great
like you you you believe that this can
happen the way j like jason momoa is
this like
warrior you know and he and he has this
sort of fighting style like you know he
throws things at them he bangs on the
ground to make them you know and it's
just and like the final episode is this
big epic battle that is so good it's
such a great epic battle that i i'm
telling you i i highly recommend you
watch this show and then there's the
characters in the show are so good uh
there's this woman her name's sylvia
hoax eight or hulk i think that's how
you say today h-o-e-k-s but she plays
queen kane
she is the most evil [ __ ] on tv man you
know you know what i mean it's very
games of thronesy e2 by the way it's got
it's got that in it too that's a great
way i forgot to say that it's very game
of thrones in terms of the intrigue
concerning some of the politics and the
and the family squabbles and
this is a really great show i'm telling
you if you've trusted me in the past
trust me now
this is the
show
i'm gonna watch it yeah you gotta watch
it watch now sit through season one
because remember season one they really
gotta establish this universe you really
have to suspend your disbelief because
at first you're kind of like what how
they doing this how they gonna be able
to do that how do you know and then you
just start to like you just go okay i
get it and they show it to you and i
think in season two they really were
very
cautious or they really were like
attentive to that they were aware of
like we got to show how these blind
people live how they've done this
and it's i'm telling you it's a really
great show and then like they really
show the the the discrepancy between you
know
people that can see and people that
can't and how
sometimes the message there is sometimes
just because you can see something
doesn't mean you can see things you know
and it that's a real powerful message
that's in the show
um
and i love it i'm telling you right now
i want you guys to go watch that show
and tell me what you think of it let me
see if anybody else in chat has uh
watched it
um
yeah
i don't know oh yeah david bautista he's
another guy that's in the show he came
he came in and season two oh and he's
great too man
oh him and
him and mom
and the other guy david and jason are
brothers and you know you know and it's
like that kind of like it's so
shakespearean
oh man i don't even want to spoil it for
you what happens in the end uh but it's
just like it's so good man i just you
know and then like you know the in this
final episode i just saw the like the
somebody i'm not gonna say who there's
like two really great speeches
two really great speeches that just like
i was crying i was like oh my god why am
i crying on this [ __ ] but it was like
really good so i will make sure you guys
uh take a look at that too man that was
like a really real it's just too really
great freaking shows all right
um make sure you guys hit the likes you
know hit the
subscribe you know what i mean like
don't don't leave me hanging right now
uh you know we want to uh
build the show up
i don't know if we're going to make an
official announcement also check out
jenna jenn my other podcast
jen the gen with matthew espinoza
um my other young influential
twenties uh good friend uh you know
we're doing that podcast and that's and
we you know we just had dane cook on we
got meghan trainor coming up in another
episode i'm gonna get one of the
bookaholics guys to come on that one we
just had these interesting discussions
about the differences in the generations
and
you know it's it's it's been pretty fun
now the dane epic dane cook episode was
really good dang really opened up it was
a really good episode so i highly
recommend you guys watch that
um and also you know i'm on king of the
sting and i don't know if they gonna
make an official announcement uh on this
next episode but i'm pretty much like
i'm on king and stink
okay so that's like uh the official
thing so now i have like three podcasts
going on
uh i appreciate them making me a part of
their thing uh theo and brendan i'm just
trying to help alleviate their stress
and just you know be another voice in
there to help them when one can't come
and the other can you know what i mean
all that kind of stuff so i'm just
trying to be
be here for for the crew and it's and
it's been fun with steve stevie wiebe
shout out to him check out uh jeremiah
wonders check out uh scissor brothers
check out um king and sting and check
out uh griffin
and once again make sure you check me
out on uh eric griffin gaming which i
will do probably
when i get off of this after i get the
episode ready for the audio because i
got to do everything right now
you know what i mean but
rip the black book
yeah the black butt went away but ladies
and gentlemen this has been another
short and sweet
episode of riffing with griffin we did
it live
um you know if you want to help support
wiggy's cat problem his cat addiction
he could pay for money okay we want to
help pay for cat food if we get a cat
food sponsorship for wig i also have a
dog too oh my god he's a nightmare he's
a zoo runner two cats two kittens
but it's good to see you again wigs
thanks for coming in to help me do this
live
uh everybody in the chat thanks for
being here uh making this special i i
love doing it live and please keep
because he's here i didn't do the
picture thing but when i'm here by
myself i mean i still i got a lot of
great pictures from people that want the
the background to be like their house or
their backyard i've gotten some really
fantastic pictures last week i had that
good cobble picture up so that was great
um
oh i should have put some pictures up of
rachel from fashion week i'm gonna do
that next week and i gotta get rachel
back on too but
yeah she did fashion week you know
rachel had this picture of herself at 16
and now she has another picture of
herself at 32
and i was like well damn she she's she's
holding up well is what i'll say my
beautiful fiance so shout out to her um
and guys uh keep watching keep
subscribing please share please like
please do all the things that make the
podcast uh grow and i appreciate all you
guys that came out to the shows and come
up to me and like i love roofing with
griffin i appreciate you guys you guys
are keeping me going and let's keep
going and i will see you
next
week
[Music]
peace
peace
just let it run for a little while
and then then turn off that one over
there you know